wenn du von frankfurt nach new york
fliegt dann dauert diese reise ganze
achteinhalb stunden
der rückflug von new york nach frankfurt
dauert allerdings eine stunde weniger
das klingt verrückt denn die strecke ist
ja genau dieselbe von new york aus bist
du aber schneller und wenn du dann also
von new york aus über europa fließt kann
es gut sein dass du einen blick auf die
zahlreichen onshore und offshore
windparks bekommst dann europaweit
drehen sich knapp 100.000 windräder alle
im uhrzeigersinn
bis jetzt denn aus demselben grund aus
dem die strecke in new york frankfurt
schneller ist sollten sich windräder in
vielen europäischen ländern eigentlich
anders herum drehen
aber bevor ich erkläre warum das so ist
einmal noch ganz kurz bewerbung ich bin
ja selber jemand der gerne dinge
aufschiebt oder auch prokrastination so
schön sagt aber jetzt ist wirklich
allerhöchste eisenbahn
denn die können nur noch bis zum 31 juli
ihre steuererklärung für das jahr
2009/10 abgeben wenn ihr dazu
verpflichtet seid seid ihr das nicht
dann lohnt es sich trotzdem sie fix zu
machen denn wenn euch das finanzamt geld
schuldet und das kann auch als student
oder azubi der fall sein dann kriegt ihr
im durchschnitt über 1000 euro zurück es
lohnt sich also
seine steuererklärung abzugeben die
sache ist nur ungefähr die hälfte der
leute die das könnte tun es nicht denn
es ist ja auch nervig und dauert lange
oder aber mit dem sponsor des heutigen
videos tax fix dort ist im durchschnitt
nur 22 minuten seine steuererklärung
abzugeben
tax fix kostet pro steuererklärung 35
euro aber auch nur wenn du mehr als 50
euro vom finanzamt zurück bekommt man
nur weniger zurück bekommt dann ist es
fix komplett gratis und mit dem kot
watson alles klein geschrieben kriegst
du auf die 35 euro nochmal 15 prozent
rabatt
du bist also kein risiko ein kriegs
durchschnittlich 4 22 minuten arbeit
über 1000 euro und hilft sogar noch
meinem kanal wenn du den aller ersten
link unten in der video beschreibung
verwendest und damit die app installiert
vielen dank
was ihr hier seht ist die corioliskraft
und dieses modell hilft uns zu verstehen
warum ein flug von westen nach osten
schneller ist als ein flug von osten
nach westen
wenn ein flugzeug von new york nach
frankfurt fliegt hat es nämlich
ordentlich rückenwind
der wind der s antreibt heißt jetstream
und blessing circa zehn kilometern höhe
von west nach ost und kann bis zu 500
kilometer pro stunde schnell werden
ursache für die corioliskraft ist die
drehung der erde um die eigene achse am
äquator dreht sich die erde mit 1670
kilometern pro stunde nach osten
je weiter man in richtung der pole geht
desto mehr nimmt diese geschwindigkeit
ab ströme luftmassen vom äquator zum
nordpol
dann nehmen sie den schwung nach osten
mit und bewegen sich dann schneller als
die erdoberfläche von der erdoberfläche
aus betrachtet sieht es so aus dass sie
von ihrem ort kurs nach osten also nach
rechts abgelenkt werden
auf dem weg zum südpol sind diese
richtungen hingegen umgekehrt die
corioliskraft führt also auf der
nordhalbkugel zu einer rechts ablenkung
und auf der südhalbkugel zu einer links
ablenkung und zwar umso stärker je näher
man den polen kommt aber was hat das
jetzt mit windrädern zu tun es gibt
super viele studien darüber in welcher
anordnung und mit welchen abständen
windräder in einem windpark am besten
aufgestellt werden sollten an die
drehrichtung der rotorblätter hat aber
bisher tatsächlich noch niemand gedacht
in einer neuen studie hat ein
deutsch-amerikanisches forschungsteam
nun herausgefunden dass wir uns die
corioliskraft hier besser zu nutzen
machen könnten
vereinfacht gesagt entnimmt ein windrad
über den rotor dem wen den windenergie
das funktioniert ähnlich wie bei einem
fahrraddynamo denn der wind versetzt
einen rotor in drehung und die
bewegungsenergie hier wird dann mit
hilfe eines generators in strom
umgewandelt
die höhe der anlage ist dabei aber
entscheidend und moderne windräder ragen
mittlerweile mehr als 150 meter in die
luft denn je höher die anlage desto
gleichmäßiger mit der wind zumindest
tagsüber hinter dem windrad können die
entkräfteten winde mit hilfe des
umgebungs windes wieder fahrt aufnehmen
ein windrad stoppt den sind also nicht
komplett so können dann also mehrere
windräder hintereinander stehen und
trotzdem strom produzieren aber je höher
ein windrad ist desto eher könnte es
dazu führen dass wir weiter oben am
windrad andere winde wehen als unten
tagsüber ist das relativ egal wenn die
aufsteigende erdwärme vermischt die
unteren luftschichten deswegen wird im
idealfall der wind in allen höhen des
windrades gleich und genau deswegen
macht die drehrichtung des windrads hier
tagsüber kein unterschied genau das
ändert sich aber bei nacht denn dann ist
der erdboden abgekühlt deswegen werden
die luftschichten nicht mehr durchmischt
und liegen stabil übereinander
das sorgt dafür dass die geschwindigkeit
des windes mit der höhe zunimmt
aber nicht nur der wind wird schneller
die corioliskraft wird auch stärker
das bedeutet nachts ist der wind am
oberen ende des windrads nicht nur
schneller sondern wird auch aus einer
anderen richtung als die winde weiter
unten im endeffekt heißt das dass der
wind sich hinter einem rechts herum
drehenden windrad links herum dreht die
computersimulation des forschungsteams
hat gezeigt dass die linksdrehenden
nachlauf finde und die rechts gelenkten
umgebungs finde sich gegenseitig
abschwächen
so nimmt der wind hinter einem windrad
nur langsamer wieder fahrt auf wer sich
jetzt aber die windräder nach links
drehen würden dann könnte der nachlauf
wind die corioliskraft mitnehmen
auf diese art und weise könnte der
schnelle umgebungs wind bei nacht dem
nachlauf wind besser erfassen und
beschleunigen
das sorgt dann für einen ordentlichen
leistungs buhs für die windräder
dahinter natürlich geht das nur für die
nordhalbkugel der erde auf der
südhalbkugel funktioniert die
corioliskraft ja genau andersherum
da ist es zufällig richtig wie die
windräder gebaut wurden aber tatsächlich
stehen auf der nordhalbkugel 90 prozent
aller windräder weltweit ein
wortwörtliche richtungswechsel könnte
also einen gewaltigen unterschied machen
theoretisch laut der studie können
linksdrehenden windräder in windparks
bei nacht bis zu 23 prozent mehr energie
gewinnen
okay das klingt mir ja cool warum machen
wir das nicht einfach
naja erstmal geht die rechnung natürlich
nur auf wenn alle windräder in einem
windpark direkt hintereinander stehen
würden
das machen sie aber logischerweise nur
wenn es nicht anders geht da man ja
dadurch energie verliert
in einem typischen windpark wie zb hier
in nrw stehen die windräder nur
teilweise hintereinander
und selbst wenn alle windräder hier in
reih und glied stehen würden müsste man
zumindest das erste windrad einer
solchen reihe immer aus der richtung
ausschließen weil dieses jahr gar nicht
erst durch den nachlauf wind eines
anderen windrads beeinflusst wird für
diesen windpark hier würde das bedeuten
dass nur circa die hälfte der windräder
von diesem effekt überhaupt profitieren
würden weil hier immer nur zwei
windräder hintereinander stehen
grob gerechnet erzeugt ein windrad genug
strom für ca 2500 haushalte pro jahr und
haushalt rechnet man mit 3000
kilowattstunden
dieser windpark ihr könnte also pro jahr
rein theoretisch durch einen
richtungswechsel knapp drei millionen
kilowattstunden mehr produzieren das
sind circa 950 haushalte also quasi als
hätte der windpark hier nachts ein
zusätzliches kostenloses windrad
es ist allerdings wichtig zu beachten
dass es sich hierbei um eine print
handelt also eine noch nicht
veröffentlichte studie das heißt sie
wurde noch nicht fertig peer reviewed
also von unabhängigen kolleginnen und
kollegen überprüft und zum beispiel auf
methodische fehler gecheckt und eine
ganze reihe von wissenschaftlern
zweifelt an dass sich die ergebnisse der
simulationen in die realität übertragen
lassen
professor doktor prang leiter des
lehrstuhls für windenergie der
universität stuttgart sagt zum beispiel
kurzfristig wird es sicherlich keine
änderung geben bei der drehrichtung das
phänomen nach lauf ist sehr komplex und
die drehrichtung ist nur einer von
vielen einflussfaktoren die die leistung
der windenergie anlagen beeinflussen
kann
wir können die komplexität der turbulenz
in der natur noch nicht sehr genau
abbilden daher ist die aussage aus
reinen simulationsstudie nimmer mit
vorsicht zu genießen es müssen noch
weitere studien folgen um den einfluss
genauer zu quantifizieren gehen wir aber
mal davon aus die ergebnisse der
simulationen lassen sich genauso in die
realität übersetzen dann haben wir ein
weiteres problem die profile der
rotorblätter müssten geändert werden
auch das getriebe dass die langsame
drehung des rotors in eine schnelle
drehung des stromgenerators übersetzt
muss neu geplant und gebaut werden
günstig ist das nicht und dass ich so
ein teurer umbau überhaupt lohnt wird
angezweifelt
das fraunhofer-institut für windenergie
systeme in bremerhaven hat sich bereits
zu dieser studie geäußert hier wird
befürchtet dass die realen
windverhältnisse von den ergebnissen der
studie abweichen könnten zumindest in
deutschland denn deutschland ist relativ
friedlich und im hügellandschaften ist
der wind abends noch so turbulent dass
sich die unteren schichten wieder
miteinander vermischen also so wie
tagsüber hier ist der effekt also
wahrscheinlich minimal
sinnvoll könnte es zum beispiel in
nordamerika sein hier herrschen die
gleichen windbedingungen die windräder
sind aber meistens in den großen flachen
planes zu finden
dort lassen sich die simulation in der
studie wahrscheinlich viel besser
reproduzieren weil es weniger stoff
faktoren wie zb hügel oder bäume gibt
und dann gibt es da noch bedenken ob
windräder die sich nicht alle in die
selbe richtung drehen vielleicht sogar
uns menschen stören würden also in etwa
so wie nicht symmetrische pflastersteine
oder ein schiefes bild das könnte
einfach irgendwie komisch aussehen und
tatsächlich wäre es ja so dass wir stück
für stück alle windräder um brüsten
müssten das heißt das wenn sich nie alle
windräder wenn dieselbe richtung drehen
alles in allem könnten bis zu 23 prozent
mehr energieausbeute durch windkraft in
der nacht aber einen großen unterschied
machen wenn das alles wirklich so klappt
und sich die umrüstung auch lohnt in
deutschland hat windenergie in diesem
jahr bisher knapp 35 prozent des
gesamten strommix das ausgemacht wenn
wir also von anfang an links drehen die
windräder gebaut hätten dann hätten wir
jetzt theoretisch bis zu 3,5 prozent
mehr strom einfach so über einen
sprichwörtlichen richtungswechsel was
umweltfreundliche energien angeht
sprechen übrigens in diesem video hier
da geht es um die fragestellung ob
kernenergie umweltfreundlich ist relativ
viele pro und contra argumente auf
beiden seiten also gerne darauf klicken
wenn euch das anschauen wollt ansonsten
bis zum 31 juli habt ihr noch zeit um
auch steuererklärung für 2009 10
abzugeben mit dem ersten linken in der
video beschreibung tax trickst dauert
das nur 22 minuten also macht schnell
dann habe das hinter euch und jetzt bin
ich gespannt was ihr zu diesem thema zu
sagen habt was glaubt ihr würde sich
lohnen unsere windräder umzubauen oder
zumindest neu gebaute windparks jetzt
links den zu machen und würde es auch
stören wenn sich alle windräder nicht in
dieselbe richtung drehen wurden
ich schreibe das gerne mal unten in die
kommentare ich bin schon sehr gespannt
was ihr dazu sagt und freue mich mit
euch zu diskutieren ansonsten wir mal
fürs zuschauern und bleibt neugierig